юрген козак активно бореться проти
правих extreme не стів винн організував
багата на акції за долар а кисть назва
жінка завтовшки нацисти домагалася далекий
від нього
the smooth томи в чат і а тривають slice
of these раціон на сюди ніс класі такий
ситуації ще в лейпцигу даяна справа не
піддавайся б заспівати і
в трамваї думаючи про чіпи лося абсолютно
не знаємо про людей нам теж таких
ситуаціях яму шури тельно продумати і
якою дорогою ми не ти так стоїш
1000 параноїдальних monsoon тут погонний
вид рахунок і женя астане сир і сотні
приходили до групи гіда виходить на вулиці
протестувати і про те рішення про ряд
криті крайон ударі сукачів при тулку
дата поважає саксонію собою вас крила
дають ісламську риторику їх через
оголене розуміння демократії я обожнюю
особливо в саксонії потрібно баха відучу
році б ти в плащі неполітично усвяти
у школі ви не значить напиши в чат і
демократії поки ті роки буду коханим
вожатим і демократію до статті
привалюю щоб активно сприйняттям ді
campo вигляд акаунт зрозумів ще проблема
популяризації ультранаціоналістів без
стрибків на таку, що збилася, причому настільки
сильно примружує до знаєте ми з його
політика такі готові публічно
камеру виступати і протонах представлений
християнсько-демократичної спілки
немічений випробувань внутрішніх справ
саксонії ми не ток i am kind нас е
проблеми справа екстремістами ми по
війні продовжила ти кинь бурхливими і не
шкіряний хто виставляю свою думку через
трубу вони зникли так ще до біженців
право екстреміст і точно не шкіри
саксон xms ми чуємо даних і до загсу
3 так він і давай завтра контекст
римського руку серце заміс ненависті їх
у нас по деваете випусти тисячі людей на
хвилі на вас тут на акцію його царик на
вулиці вийшло на 20 тисяч людей
результаті скажи не групи нацисти в
руколи з місця полетимо на порошку
джалла ви напали на наш завершений
концерт політ просто до вилаз на
цехів
типу обличчя succession out there i reach
організатори акції з діваються шукає
демонстрації за свободу ревнив та уманець
адже будете без інцидентів